it's exactly like you know when you when
you go to like a chinese restaurant with
your one chinese mate and they're like
yeah bring out the special thank you
bring out the real me i don't know why
it's like chinese restaurants in
particular but it seems like every
chinese restaurant has the special menu
that you can only that you can only get
by asking in cantonese or manchester
united or whatever and i bet they're not
even saying like bring out the real
minions probably just like a code word
you know
it's like
mandarin is an orange and they're like i
said the word
bring it out right now i just like it
just it just blows my mind because like
you know i go to a thai restaurant and i
can ask them in thai whether they have
you know a you know a thai dish that's
uh they like they only like do in
thailand or only time most pi thai
people would know but like it's just
like why is it that chinese restaurant
just have an unspoken understanding that
there's going to be so many people
asking for a special menu that they're
going to make a special menu in every
single choice why are they literally
gatekeeping
it's like
literally gatekeeping be like if you're
not chinese you can't get the real [ __ ]
you know
it makes me feel sad though because i
love chinese food i know right i never
want to go to a chinese restaurant
without a chinese i know i know right
sucks because it feels like you've just
unlocked the starter the starter kit
right and you need to learn mandarin to
get to get like the actual good gear
right
do you know what i mean because like i
love chinese food but the best chinese
food i've had has not come from the
normal menu no like if i go to like a
chinese restaurant and i see like
[ __ ] you know orange chicken sweet
and sour chicken fried rice all this
stuff i was like this no no give him the
real [ __ ] give him please give me the
real [ __ ] but i i don't know how to
access it like where is your chinese
friend
i do not know i don't see him
you just just just speak chinese right
just just speak mandarin it's easy just
eating exactly
could you imagine if like mcdonald's did
that it's like oh where's your american
friend wait well i know shake shack does
though does it do they yeah they were
secret they have secret items really
yeah i didn't know that you didn't know
this
no shake shack sorry uh uh i don't know
internet oh in and out i got it in an
hour
special menu
you can get like the
you can i i don't know it's like animal
style fries that's a secret menu oh yeah
yeah i know that yeah and then there's
like a is that a secret menu that i feel
that's like so well known now but if
you're like uh if you're a tourist from
asia don't speak english oh that's true
you're like and you're like what what's
that guy called how do i get something
else yeah
i know you can get a flavor where like
they mix all the
uh
um or the milkshake flavors into one oh
which sounds sounds interesting yeah so
if you want that
i think there's something else there's
another secret burger or something as
well i know there are secret items that
fast food chains are secret items items
yeah i don't know that because because
they don't because the pain in the ass
to make but is it a marketing thing
also that as well yeah yeah it makes you
seem like you're you're like in this
club part of the secret society yeah i i
got the real stuff give me give me the
real stuff you've been to those like uh
places that are like secret uh bars or
clubs or anything oh like they invite
only ones yeah yeah
yeah one of my friends took me to one
where it was literally it's in tokyo i'm
obviously not going to say where but
like it literally just
i don't know
i've been i've been there it literally
looks like a
concrete wall
and he just like like i was with my
friend and he's like okay we're here and
i'm like what do you mean
where is this
it's like uh it's in roppongi somewhere
i think we went to one in shibuya right
yeah that's easy they said like closed
and it was like closed due to corona oh
yeah yeah yeah someone like knocked on
the door and they came out so it was it
was literally it wasn't he wasn't even
just look it looked close it was just
scaffolding and like and like oh
like this place was like being built
yeah
and you just knock on the door and like
a like an actual speakeasy like the
[ __ ]
thing opens up yeah my my one had that
as well so like he knocked like he he's
like oh i have to knock a specific way
as well i'm like a [ __ ] you do and
he did like a secret like pattern and
then the thing came up and he's like
password
and then he said the password and he's
like
friend
he pointed at me and he's like yeah
friend i was like
okay
and then he opens it up and it's just
this tiny like maybe three person bar
right and uh i mean it was all right i
guess it was all right it was cool that
i was in the coolest part it was just
going to uh what looked like a secret
bar the coolest part was just like the
dude opening up like this i'm like i've
only ever seen that movie i went to one
where it was in london um i went to it
and it was like a it's like a
breakfast restaurant or something
on the top yeah we went in there and i
didn't know the password and neither did
my friend and then we were like
we don't know what the password is yeah
he was like
it's a daft punk song lyric
and then he was like he's like giving
clothes he was like feeling it to me and
i was like it was something like i'm up
all night to get lucky or something
right okay so he said it then he was
like it's not even like an obscure darth
park song no no you just go through the
entire disciples i was like which which
album which we were talking about okay
okay can't be too many lyrics yeah if
it's dark punk lyrics that that narrows
is it around the world so then um
we're here and then some guy comes and
greets us and we start walking through
this uh restaurant that's closed
and then like in a movie we go in the
kitchen and there's people like working
in the kitchen and we're just like
walking through
oh [ __ ] and we go down into a basement
in the kitchen and there's like boxes of
fries and [ __ ] all around us
yeah and then like like like in like in
a [ __ ] spy movie it's got the [ __ ]
beads
oh [ __ ]
opens it up this this room it means it's
[ __ ]
lit room it's it's like
it's okay but there's like no uh real
like chairs or anything it's kind of
like a
a very small room that's very dimly lit
and it didn't it wasn't that good the
drinks are okay yeah and i was like this
is the coolest part was walking to this
thing oh yeah yeah yeah i want to leave
yeah what i've always wanted to know
what why would you opt to make a
business like that right like you i feel
yeah i feel clearly like if you're going
to opt to be like okay i'm going to make
this so exclusive that it's like near
impossible for a regular person to find
then it's like you're clearly not doing
it
as a sustainable business you know
you're clearly doing it as like a
[ __ ] horse i mean it's the assumption
is you'll be able to survive on word of
mouth i guess that's that's the hope a
lot of people like it's so cool you
gotta go yeah and then the drinks are
very mediocre yeah the experience feels
worth it because you feel exclusive yeah
i mean just bragging rights right yeah
you pay for the experience and not so
much the you know the bar or the
business or the uh drinks itself it's
like it's like bars that are membership
only
right and you can only get membership by
having someone recommend you
like that that always seemed really
silly to me but there's so many of them
well that's like that's like like half
of like the golden guy yeah membership
half of the niche as well is like that
as well yeah it's like if you don't know
someone who either works there or goes
there frequently enough they just won't
let you in yeah yeah but at the same
time like i i can get it with the bars
and golden guy because the bars are so
small
that i'm sure that their regular
customers can keep them keep their
business up and running yeah anyway you
just need like one or two patrons so you
keep get yourself going and then you're
basically set that's true that's true i
basically said it'd be pretty cool to
own a like tiny little bar in golden gai
i've always thought about that
but it's like what but like it's like to
get a bar there yeah that's what i've
always wanted i'm like you're but like
all those bars even though they're so
tiny i'm sure they're paying out the ass
to have that space what's the trash
taste bar there of trash day spa and
gold taste special build a bar build a
bar in golden gate all three of us build
our own bars and golden gate see who
makes the most money at the end of the
night i don't even want to do that i
didn't even want a mystical nightmare i
didn't even want to think about how much
it must cost to like rent out a space
i'd get really claustrophobic walking uh
working on one of those
it's cozy i think it's cozy
yeah it depends i've been in i've been
in somewhere it's like i i literally
can't stand up straight inside of them
right
it's literally a shoebox yeah it is um
and i don't even know how they get into
the bar let alone work well most of them
are like you know four feet tall like
all barchans right
they probably don't have any problems
it's not built for someone of my stature
like if i stand up i literally my my
like head literally hits the ceiling
like i feel like gandalf in frodo's
house in a lot of these places around
i'm just constantly like can i get a
drink please
normally if you're wide that's the
problem though not not if you're tall
yeah yeah that's true but that's why
like going in the winter time is the
worst because you're like all puffed up
with jackets and [ __ ] just like all
right out of the way please sorry excuse
me because i think it's best to get a
though in the summer if it's weird i
don't know why i feel in the summer it's
just way too hot it's really hot yeah
even though the ac is going it's still
though either way it's it's very much a
gamble
i've i've heard so many horror stories
in golden gai and like nietzsche and all
that kind of stuff don't go into your
bar if someone tells you to go into a
bar that's the rule of thumb yeah yeah
if somebody's trying to tell you to go
into their bar that's probably a good
sign to not guarantee that's probably a
bad idea what would be on like the
japanese secret menu there was like uh
if you want to if you went to like
or something yeah i don't know i feel
like we don't have secret menus here
either just because like we don't even
have tipping culture here yeah because
we're so like just so like these are the
rules we can't make any kind
something you feel of
of it right
well like what i'm talking about is if
you go to a japanese restaurant not in
japan oh i said what would be like the
foods on there that would be something
that you a japanese person very
accustomed to japanese cuisine would
know but not is like i guess not
mainstream enough to be on like to be so
you're asking what the most underrated
japanese food is
like or like unknown
i would say it'd probably be something
slimy like most of the [ __ ] that we
ended up feeling in the uh what's in the
box and the charities like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that
yeah yeah probably something like that
like maybe like i don't know um
natto on in curry maybe because i feel
like a lot of izakaya foods would be on
there oh yeah definitely like
yeah like uh like the blended squid and
stuff like that or like takawasa that
[ __ ]
oh that's just ball oh no way no way hey
man you're you're part of my team now
because you're like natto okay natto
natto was actually right it was it was
all right the taste is fine but the
slime is just dreadful yeah really vile
the slime is it's not even the worst
texture i've had in japan i feel like
it looks a lot worse than it tastes and
feels in your mouth i think like i think
the beans taste pretty good i mean it
just tastes
like soy sauce i think i mean it smells
basically what it is i mean that's what
it is soy sauce on soy beans yeah yeah
soy overload right right i mean i feel
though if because you guys ate it like
straight out of the packet you got like
the full brunt of like the the sliminess
and the texture but like when you put
that on a bed of rice because you're
eating it with rice it doesn't feel as
slimy yeah i feel like sure like with a
bit of rice it would be perfect it would
be absolutely fantastic yeah i mean i i
guess you know you gotta you gotta give
it a go give it a go give it a go if you
don't like it it's totally fine maybe
maybe you'll like it maybe you're not
yeah like i did to me like i i learned
that uh i just can't handle ketchup i i
don't know why i don't know why like
that was the first time
that was that was a lot of kids that was
the first time like so what yeah
live stream to explain we all had four
fits to do i had to eat pizza crust
drenched in ketchup and mayonnaise
because i hate ketchup and mayonnaise
and
i don't need the crust and then i don't
need the crust and i remember like i was
like i'm gonna give this the best go
that i possibly can because this is for
charity and it's the first time where
i've put something in my mouth and i had
like immediate gag reflux
like to me like natto like i was just
like maybe i'm going to gag during the
nasa and i had it and i'm just like it's
because you expected to gag i think you
expected to like throw up so you're you
were psyching yourself out the moment
you it touched your tongue you're like
yeah um to be fair that
smells pretty dreadful like yeah i
actually liked it
actually liked it
southeast asians all right
you're the exception you're the
exception to the rule he's british when
it counts yeah when it doesn't he's like
no no
i choose my nationality depending
on [ __ ] i i can't do this card right
when you what you're either the best i
can do is that someone's like wow your
country's a colonizer i'm like no no i
wasn't i was whales
i'm the culprit and the victim at the
same time
nothing to do with me i didn't do
anything